[Musique]
le tiers de la terre brûlée
le fier de la mère de vincent
le tiers des fleuves de 20h05
deux tiers du ciel s'obscurcit
séquence on
cataclysme 2
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce nom
au fait il
les feux grillés de sont précipités sur
la terre le tiers de la thèse qui brûle
et tiennent des arbres
nous
[Musique]
oh
à eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le deuxième manche sonna de la trompette
est comme une grande montagne tout
embraser de feu fut jeté dans la mer
tiers de la mère de vincent et le tiers
des créatures marines amis vivent perry
et le tiers de la ville
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pierre-henri cette musique étrange ces
sons qui viennent de nulle part
en fait qui viennent nous demande
magnétique qui viennent du dub un
travail absolument techniques du son ces
sons qui n'ont plus besoin d'instruments
qui n'ont plus besoin d'orchestre
en fait vous aussi vous êtes un de ceux
qui ont complètement changé qui ont fait
basculer en quelques sortes la musique
contemporaine puisque vous vous privez
complètement des instruments habituels
pour employer les instruments techniques
mais en fait je veux savoir qu'est ce
que ça vous a apporté qu'est ce que en
fait je dois vous dire qu'on vienne de
moi et que je suis à moi tout seul tous
les instruments donc ça m'a apporté une
chose fantastique ça m'a permis de me
révéler à moi par moi même et de et de
composer cima cema
façon de composer depuis 20 ans et je
travaille avec tous les sons si bien le
son à ce moment tôt que les sons vocaux
les sons électroniques comme ce que vous
avez fait avec leurs caisses peuvent
anglais l'esprit qui tous par exemple
oui c'est une autre expérience marginal
mais en fait vous trouvez que ça se
situe dans un même courant je veux dire
la musique disons à partir des sons de
magnétophone enfin pour employer une
expression si vous voulez un peu
simpliste peut-être mais par rapport à
une musique de concert habituel ce que
je voulais dire c'est que lorsque vous
trouvez que la démarche
la véritable démarche du compositeur est
différente nom du président qui écrit
des notes important travail pas bon du
tout au contraire je me sens toujours
très musiciens mais mes études
classiques mais ça va encore beaucoup ce
que j'ai pu apprendre au conservatoire
où avec olivier messiaen et cc c'est
toujours en moi seulement les moyens de
m'exprimer sont complètement différent
ils sont modernes
oui mais ce que les moyens d'expression
ne change pas ici le contenu de la
musique quand même pour moi je ne crois
pas c'est une musique actuelle mais fait
avec des moyens traditionnels puisque
j'utilise les instruments mais quand
vous dites actuelles justement
j'aimerais croire en quoi et pourquoi
cette actuelle est actuel parce que
cette musique est faite avec des
techniques actuelles avec des
instruments électroniques avec des
magnétophones mais la pensée enfin moi
je crois que je suis un compositeur
traditionnels utilisant des moyens des
moyens du futur est en fait c'est moins
du futur vous donne quand même peut-être
une liberté un peu plus grande
pas tellement parce que le
les matériaux sont tellement riche qu'il
faut choisir qu'il faut pratiquer une
certaine ascèse et je me sens pas du
tout libre au contraire vous sentez
portée je me sens porté inspiré je crois
que il ya une notion d'inspiration qui
existent aussi dans cette musique est ce
que vous rencontrez auprès du public dès
le départ afin l'adhésion que vous un
peu plus maintenant mais je dois dire
que les plus intenses étaient souvent
très dur de faire passer cette musique
parfois maintenant elle passe maintenant
elle passe un peu partout enfin c'est à
dire que je vais je multiplie les
concerts et les choix que vous en faites
en juin prochain le 6 juin à saint denis
donc on voit avec l'apocalypse justement
vous avez pu voir les sons l'apocalypse
le magnétophone
tout ça c'est la musique de demain mais
aussi j'espère un compositeur
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]